hey youtubers what's up so this is gonna
be my flash episode 10 video there were
a whole bunch of new characters so I'll
try and explain who all them are from
the comics in addition to my top 5
moments and Easter eggs so here we go
I'll start with a spoiler warning right
now because I'm gonna explain who all
that comic book characters are that we
saw for the first time so first up
obviously is McCrory aka heatwave played
by Dominic Purcell Prison Break reunion
all the way so much fun I'll talk about
him in top five moments there's a whole
bunch I could say about him then we also
got the wrath of ways the wrath aways
are the really wealthy parents of Pied
Piper one of the Rogues that we're gonna
see next week in next week's episode we
met Jason Rusch who's part of the
firestorm mythos in the comics the
show's gonna do something a little bit
different with them but I'll explain in
a sec and then finally we met in credits
teaser new rogue who you know if you
haven't seen the episode yet I'm gonna
wait till I get to the end of the video
before I talk about her but very cool
person showing up so here we go getting
into top five moments number five flash
training montage very strong way to come
into the back half of the season like
come in running literally Barry has
totally drank Harrison wells kool-aid in
his training so that he could beat the
reverse-flash eventually funny because
Harrison said that they're partners now
I hope you don't think of me as an enemy
probably one of the best lines in the
episode Tom Cavanaugh actually said
recently in a bunch of interviews that
every time he has a line he tries to
build in double meanings and in the way
that he says things so if you feel like
something he said sounds ominous it's on
purpose like he's doing that as an actor
on purpose as cool as Barry turning
around and throwing the missile was
really it was Harrison putting his foot
on the ground for just like for just a
brief second they were teasing that he
you know he might SuperSpeed run and
save Barry so that he wouldn't die all
this Harrison wells partnership
reverse-flash training is to make Barry
better we still don't know what Harrison
wells wants to use him for presumably
it's a causality loop that somehow helps
Harrison's reverse-flash whatever
version of the reverse-flash he is I
still feel like he's the a o'Barr Thawne
version just because he's a little bit
smarter a lot of people have pointed to
the fact that Eddie Thawne could also
become really super smart because if he
gets flash powers his brain will work
just as fast as grant gustin's does but
when you think about it Grant Gustin
reading those 800 pages so he has
trained
as a scientist gaining SuperSpeed
doesn't give you super comprehension
so if eddie thawne were to read those
800 pages at SuperSpeed he'd read the
words but that doesn't necessarily mean
he'd understand what it means that's why
I think that Harrison wells
reverse-flash is going to be the smarter
of the reverse flashes even though
during episode nine I think that's the
same reverse flash
I think it's Harrison wells from two
different times I know it gets a little
complicated but I think at some point
Eddie Thawne will get reverse flash
powers he'll just be closer to the
hunter zolomon version less scientific
but every bit is dangerous
number four meet McCrory aka heatwave so
I've already done a background video on
heat wave like an explainer video about
him in the comics so I had a link to
that just in general let's let's talk
about Dominic Purcell performance how
much fun was it seeing him go all Creepo
on Caitlyn I wonder what the producers
told Dominic whenever they were asking
him to take the role like whenever they
were auditioning him McCrory as a
character is a pyromaniac he is in love
with the idea fire obsessed with fire
and I feel like Dominic Purcell did an
amazing job
at making us feel that clearly he has
been touched by flame actually actually
in a literal sense the really
interesting thing about his relationship
with Captain cold is that it kind of
mirrors Barry in Harrison wells
relationship they're kind of like
frenemies although Barry doesn't quite
know it yet one of the characters is
just a little more aware of the other
and in the case of the Rogues Captain
Cold is tolerating heatwave and in the
case of the reverse flash Harrison wells
is tolerating Barry Allen because he has
to one needs the other four very
important plan in the case of the Rogues
they're trying to get that super
valuable painting in the case of the
reverse-flash obviously his plan is much
grander involves time travel it doesn't
always happen on every show but a lot of
comic book characters are set up that
way where they have a diametric opposite
that they have some sort of symbiotic
relationship with very awesome to see
the official debut of the Rogues
obviously based on the end of the
episode that's only going to continue
they're only gonna grow in ranks I keep
saying it like the back half of the
season is gonna be very rogue heavy the
reverse-flash is always going to be the
biggest villain he'll always be the
biggest flash villain but the Rogues
will fill the void in the meantime so
we're gonna meet a whole bunch of rogues
number three Caitlin chases
down project firestorm and jason rusch
this is another really huge comic book
moment jason rusch is officially on the
show now apparently not as part of the
firestorm matrix that's kind of the way
they started out of the comics normally
firestorm is made up of two people
Ronnie Raymond and Professor Martin
Stein but at a certain point in the
comics jason rusch became firestorm
Ronnie Raymond died went away so the
show is making it a little bit simpler
they're just going with the original
configuration but at some point in the
future jason rusch could become part of
the firestorm matrix but i mean that's a
long ways off they're just getting
started with firestorm character they
were at the tcas
here's actually here's a picture of what
the costume is supposed to look like
part of the fun of meeting Jason Rusch
was getting this secondary storyline
that's gonna run across the back half of
the season you know what's going on with
Project firestorm something really shady
Robbie Amell and Victor Garber Victor
Garber is the actor playing Martin Stein
they talked about the possibility of a
firestorm spin-off show right now the
only new spin-off that they're
officially working on the CW is the atom
show for Brin and rouse character but it
is possible that the next spin-off may
be in like another year or two if things
go well there could be a separate
firestorm show just for Robbie Mel's
character that's just like something
floating in the periphery so keep that
in the back of your mind of all of all
the characters to get a spinoff he would
ply be one of the he would probably be
at the top of the list number two Eddie
Thawne helps the flash and apparently
now they're best buds
initially it kind of seemed like Eddie
really hated the flash based on their
past runnin by the end of the episode it
seemed like he really respected and
loved what the flash did so they might
start working together like you might
see a partnership developed between the
flash obviously using his crazy voice
and Eddie Thawne of all the possible
reasons that an Eddie Thawne
reverse-flash would hate the crap out of
Barry Allen it could be that he develops
a working relationship with the flash
not knowing that he's Barry Allen then
Barry on steals his girlfriend in real
life then he finds out the flash is
Barry Allen and hates his guts that's
why I think the iris is gonna be much
more important to the back half of the
season as a character she's not really
central to the plot right now but she is
like the wheel around which Barry and
Eddie are turning right now I feel like
she's going to become a focal point it
just feels like a very simple way to
put eddie thawne in barry allen in
opposition if you haven't read the
comics hunter zolomon was the person
that became the reverse-flash the zoom
reverse flash he used to be really good
friends with wally west but then the big
tragedy happened he became the
reverse-flash and then started doing
terrible terrible things to Wally so it
just feels like they're pushing eddie
thawne in a hunter zolomon direction and
my number one moment the flash first the
Rogues and Captain Cold sister shows up
at the end so big action set piece
really fun cross the streams Ghost
Buster style I totally love all the
shout outs Cisco gets so meta and then I
like that he's kind of gotten Harrison
wells caught up in it too
he is the reverse-flash but that doesn't
mean that he also doesn't like to have
fun every once in a while as great as
the resolution was it just it was so
much more fun finding out that it was
part of Captain Colts plan all along
that they get caught say anything you
want about all the Rogues Captain Cold
Oh is a master planner he's really good
usually when things fall apart it's when
people like heatwave go off-book that's
usually the downfall of the Rose is when
they all start fighting each other I
know I didn't explain her at the
beginning of the video either but
Captain Cold sister that we saw the
tease of at the end in the comics she's
known as golden glider she's she's a
full-on rogue she does have power she
commits crimes with them but she has the
ability to phase through walls the
person playing her is Payton list from
The Tomorrow People I don't know if
she's ever gonna get any scenes with
Robbie Amell doing firestorm stuff but
that would be so much fun I'm not
expecting it so now you can add the
Tomorrow People of the list of shows
that the flash and arrow pull from you
have Prison Break Spartacus and now the
Tomorrow People I have no idea which
episode Lisa snart is gonna show up in
for the first time they made it seem
like she's gonna show up next week even
though next week is supposedly a Pied
Piper heavy episode as soon as she does
show up we can talk a lot more about her
here's my big question for you guys do
you think that Eddie Thawne is going to
start developing kind of a side
partnership with the flash you know
teaming up to take down criminals
without knowing he's Barry Allen do you
think that that's gonna develop between
the two of them so time for Easter eggs
so they were actually a whole bunch in
the episode I think I already mentioned
a lot of them so I'll just I'll brush
through these really quick Barry Allen
says he's not the fastest man alive that
distinction goes to the reverse-flash in
the comics zoom the hunter zolomon zoom
actually becomes faster than the flash
because his powers are based on a
different principle
when Harrison Wells says after this past
Christmas I think he poses a threat to
both of us talking about captain cold
the cold gun is the only known weapon
that's effective against the flash and
the reverse flashes powers inside Barry
Allen's childhood backpack there's a
Space Ghost comic Space Ghost Coast to
Coast that's all I could think about the
first time I saw it I actually thought
it was a Batman comic but then I looked
at it a second time and saw that it was
Space Ghost Jason Rusch also named Rob
mercury labs now we visited there in
episode 9 but max mercury was part of
the flash family and andrew kriesberg
at the TCS recently said that this back
half of the season is going to fully
explore the lore of the reverse-flash
when he said it he made it sound like
they're going to incorporate all aspects
of the reverse flash not just one or two
reverse flashes but several from the
comics I've already done a video for
like for all the different reverse
flashes so I'll add a link to that in
the description if you guys want to
learn more about the different versions
if you saw any other Easter eggs that I
didn't mention just right and below in
the comments or actually ghostbusters
although I did mention that although I
love the idea that Cisco said that it's
scientifically accurate I actually I
don't know that it is but it might be so
there were a couple thumbs down I had on
the episode just a couple of things I
feel didn't work quite as well as they
could have so just the idea of people
living at their parents houses beyond a
certain age that just kind of bugs me a
little bit they're kind of fuzzy on how
old Barry and iris are I would say
mid-20s maybe so I guess you could
believe them living at Joe's house if
you really think about it it'd be much
more practical for Barry to just go live
at STAR Labs and then Caitlin talking to
Jason Rusch about this big mystery big
plot that they were trying to tease I
feel like they you know quote-unquote
rushed that a little bit not to make too
many puns but I feel like they were
trying to set up this huge mystery plot
that's gonna involve the military and a
bunch of other characters and it just it
felt like they dived into that too fast
like it was a little unbelievable how
quickly he got crazy in that meeting and
he actually did come off a little bit
crazy they're after me I kept wondering
if I missed the scene I was like maybe I
missed a line or something overall I
thought it was a really strong episode
great way to bring us back into the
season and tease the idea of all these
new Rogues showing up as well as all
this firestorm stuff I'm sure you guys
have a ton of questions about the comic
book characters as well as Harrison
wells reverse-flash stuff Eddie Thawne
so leave
everything in the comments I will be
doing a Q&A for arrow in the flash on
Thursday but I'll try to answer as many
comments on this video in the comments
as possible in related news tomorrow I'm
actually going to be going on CW fan
talk I'm supposed to be on with Emily
BETT Rickards so I don't know how that's
gonna go
I could embarrass myself quite a bit
it's gonna be a lot of fun either way I
won't be uploading that video it's not
my show but if you follow me on Twitter
I'll tweet the link out before I go on
it's gonna start at 4 p.m. Pacific time
so it'll go on an hour before arrow airs
that video for arrow will post just
after the episode airs just like normal
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything if you have any special
requests for the Q&A video or anything
you want me to include just let me know
well you guys wait for all that to
happen you can click here to learn more
about heatwave from the comics for his
character history and you can click here
for my new weekly facepalm video it's
just gonna be a catch-all for stuff that
doesn't necessarily fit into like Star
Wars or Avengers or arrow or flash
videos so thank you so much for watching
so let's all high-five I will see you
guys tomorrow
you